وسؤالي هو حول شكل الرد المتوقع من الجيش
الاسرائيلي بعد هذا الحادث اذا ما بنينا
على حالات
سابقه لا لا لا يوجد رد بالنسبه للجيش
الاسرائيلي لانه عمليا يفعل كل
شيء لم يبقي طريقه للعمل او اليه للعمل
الا واتبعها الجيش الاسرائيلي ما تعرف
بالاحزمه
الناريه المهوله التي يتم تنفيذها ن تم
تنفيذها خلال الايام الماضيه في المغازي
وخانيونس تحديدا وبشكل واسع وكبير هذه هذه
الاحزمه التي عمليا يتم استهداف المناطق
السكنيه حتى اثناء وجود السكان فيها ويتم
تدميرها بشكل كامل هذا هذا عمليا رد الفعل
او يمكن نسميه الجيش الاسرائيلي بشكل كامل
لن يستطيع ان يفعل الجيش الاسرائيلي يفعل
في غزه اقصى ما يمكن ان تتخيله لذلك رده
الفعل لن تكون اكثر من استمرار هذه الحاله
الموجوده وهذا وهذا ضمن الاشكاليات التي
يقع فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي انه عمليا هو
يعني ينفذ كل الجرائم التي يرتكبها
والاعدامات والاباده وال سياسه الارض
المحروقه
والتطهير المناطق السكنيه بشكل كامل
وتهجير المواطنين منها لا يستطيع ان يفعل
اكثر مما فعل في هذه العمليه ونحن نتحدث
عمليا بالمناسبه عن منطقه مثل المغازي
عمليا اباد او قام بمسح جزء مهم خاصه في
المناطق الشرقيه حتى في مناطق ما تعرف
بقرب منط ق صلاح الدين مدخل مخيم المغازي
والمواطنون غالبيه في المواطنين نزحوا من
هذه المناطق عمليا لن يستطيع ان يفعل اكثر
مما فعلوا هذه عمليا الجيش الاسرائيلي هو
نتاج نتاج سياساته التي يتبعها ضد
المواطنين الفلسطينيين والمقاومه تتصدى
لهذا العمل لذلك لا نتوقع رده فعل رده
الفعل حقيقه ق يكون على الصعيد السياسي
فيما يتعلق بموقف الجيش الاسرائيلي وانا
اعتقد انه اعتراف الجيش الاسرائيلي بهذا
العدد في ظل عدد من الت تسريبات خلال
الايام الماضيه عن الجيش الاسرائيلي و انه
عمليا يقوم باعمال خارقه في قطاع غزه
يحاول ان يضغط على المستوى السياسي اولا
ليوصل رساله انه هناك صعوبات كبيره في
العمل الميداني داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي في
قطاع غزه وانه استمرار العمليه و وعمليا
نتحدث عن اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر والرساله
الثانيه انه يريد ان يقول انه العمل
العسكري لا يمكن ان يوصل الى ال الجنود
والاسر قطاع غزه وخاصه العمليه التي
اطلقها وزير الجيش في منطقه خان يونس كل
هذه قد تكون رسائل لانه الاعتراف بهذا
العدد هو بالمناسبه في المرات الماضيه كان
يعترف بالتدريج بالاعداد اثنان ثم ثلاثه
ثم خمسه ثم يبرر انه العمليات حدث في في
ظروف معينه لكن ان يتحدث بشكل واضح عن هذا
العدد الكبير من القتلى هذا سابقه خلال
هذه الحرب قد تكون الاولى التي يعترف فيها
الجيش الاسرائيلي بشكل مباشر وعلمي عن هذا
العدد الكبير من القتله وقد تكون رساله
للقياده السياسيه الاسرائيليه ان الجيش
يفعل كل شيء في قطاع غزه لكن هو يتعرض الى
خسائر كبيره قد لا يحتملها الجيش
الاسرائيلي نحن نتحدث عن عمليه تصل الى 23
جندي او 24 جندي اسرائيلي وضابط لهذا
العدد نحن نتحدث عن ما يمكن ان نسميه قمه
نخبه الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليا في داخل
الميدان هذا الجانب قد يشكل عامل ضغط على
القياده السياسيه الاسرائيليه ليقول انه
الجيش اسرائيلي يستنفذ كل ويدفع الثمن
وايضا في السياق هي ايضا رساله للجمهور
الداخلي الاسرائيلي انه هو الجيش يدفع
الثمن هذه القرارات قد يكون انعكاساته
داخليه اسرائيليه خلال الايام الماضيه
عفوا القادمه لكن ندرك انه خلال الساعات
الصعبه لا تخرج تصريحات اسرائيليه تنتقد
الجيش او تنتقد القياده
السياسيه